now you recently met the Queen of
England that is an amazing Ewing how did
that have come about honestly I just I
got a I got a email in my inbox from the
Secretary of the masters of the house
inviting us to Buckingham Palace and
immediately I thought it was a joke and
now who's us it was my wife and I okay I
didn't know if this was a cast thing
this no no no just me that was so stupid
I said that but this makes no sense so I
got invite you actually you were were
you you you spent some time in London I
did I was born in London those other
guys you were born there yes exactly and
I thought it was a joke I thought one of
my friends was playing a prank on me
because that's exactly what they would
do yeah send me to England and I show my
ID and they wouldn't let me into the
palace and they're like I got you yeah
and so we got invited and then when I
accepted we got this beautiful
invitation he went to London showed up
to Buckingham Palace you know in a nice
suit and everything and the the the
palace is actually facade when you drive
through it's not the entrance there's
another courtyard and then the entrance
I'm not sure if I'm I'd love to say that
anyway I'll see you guys never bye so we
didn't be joined as a store in the back
that's always on wah I know and so we
got in and then this gentleman comes
escorts us and says and I said where are
we going they're like well you're about
to meet the Queen and they give us all
these rules about you have to bow you
have to curtsy and now I'm freaking out
I'm freaking out the Queen's about to
enter through the doors I don't know
what they're saying
so she enters through the doors and I
begin to have a panic attack and I'm
like I'm gonna faint
that's the Queen what's gonna happen to
me why am I thinking that way what's
wrong with me oh I'm fine oh why am i
sweating do I smell that's weird and I
start having this conversation right and
then the Queen has a hand out and I
shake it and I'm like hi your majesty
and she's like and she says nice to see
you again and I was like I'm not Dave
Patil but have you met her before I've
never met her before
you